missouri's last abortion clinic could be
shut down this Friday because the state
is refusing to renew Planned
Parenthood's license now this story was
first reported by CBS news.com and it
comes just days after the governor there
Mike Parsons his name signed a bill into
law banning abortion after eight weeks
of pregnancy with no exceptions for rape
or incest Missouri is one of six states
to pass similar laws as here none of
those laws have taken effect yet if the
st. Louis clinic closes Missouri will
become the first state effectively to
end all legal abortion service since Roe
versus Wade established that right back
in 1973 we reached out to Governor
parson and the Missouri Department of
Health and Senior Services but they did
not provide a comment Planned Parenthood
is suing to keep providing abortions at
that clinic with an emergency court
hearing today the organization's
president and CEO dr. Lena wen is with
us good morning dr. Winn thanks for
being here good morning the new law in
Missouri does not actually go into
effect until the end of August what is
the state telling you about why it may
not renew the clinics license well this
is a real public health crisis that's
happening right now because we could
face a situation where by the end of the
week more than 1.1 million women in
Missouri will have abortion inaccessible
in their own state
so abortion remains legal but if it's
inaccessible then for all intents and
purposes women just are not able to
access essential health care what are
you expecting at the hearing today well
we hope that the court will see exactly
what's happening which is that over the
last 10 years the state of Missouri has
imposed regulation upon regulation that
has no basis in medicine we've complied
with all of them because we want to keep
our health center open these are things
like making our hallways extra wide
forcing women to wait 72 hours even
having unnecessary invasive pelvic exams
is it that dangerous it's bad for health
care it's also traumatizing for women
especially women who've suffered sexual
assault and rape and we've done this
because we want to keep on providing
health care but now the state is
threatening to prosecute our doctors the
bill that the governor just signed would
put doctors up to 15 years in prison for
providing medical care and that's just a
terrifying reality for women and often
what do you think doctor Wynn that
people don't understand how serious this
is people need to understand that this
is not a drill it's not hypothetical
Missouri could become the first state in
nearly 50 years to have no abortion care
in the entire state and I want people to
know that Planned Parenthood will always
fight for women we will always be here
well fight in the courts we'll find out
the legislators and we need everyone's
support to fight these extreme bans that
are happening around the country Planned
Parenthood is more than just abortions I
think people need to understand that too
we have Planned Parenthood are proud to
provide the full spectrum of
reproductive health care cancer
screenings affordable birth control STI
HIV tests and yes safe legal abortion
care because that's what it is it's
health care and we have plan parent to
do more to prevent unintended
pregnancies than any other organization
you know we've tried to reach out to the
state of Missouri and the Department of
Health there we haven't heard back don't
they have a right under the law to
impose these restrictions well what they
are doing is to weaponize the inspection
process and to politicize it I'm a
former health conditioning it's not in
good faith not at all in fact they have
said that their intention the state of
Missouri has said and anti women's
health politicians have said that all
these regulations have only one purpose
which is to shut down the ability of
health centers to provide safe legal
abortions which is not going to stop
abortion but it will stop safe legal
abortions and the cost will be women's
lives you were at the clinic in Missouri
yesterday that's right well were the
doctors there telling you well I met
with the staff the doctors and nurses
and other clinicians there and our staff
are saying that they think that's coming
for years because they have been on the
front lines of having all these
requirements imposed on them that
they've had to meet and now this is
coming this is a warning to everyone in
the country that this is not a drill
I've heard you say that this is per
so for you this particular case how so I
was a medical student at Washington
University in st. Louis I volunteered at
that Health Center and I've seen for
myself the women who already travel
hundreds of miles to access essential
health care and now to see that
healthcare literally being taken away
that will endanger women's lives in
particular women with low-income women
who have to travel from rural areas and
it's this is what's happening around the
country this is the real impact of these
terrible laws that are being passed dr.
Lena Wynn thank you for joining us we
have to go but I do want to point out
donations they are going up true they
are and I hope that people will keep on
supporting Planned Parenthood and other
organizations that provide essential
health as you say it's not a drill thank
you very much we appreciate it